this is a production of Cornell
University good morning and welcome to
commencement Sunday at Cornell we're
really excited to have everyone here and
I was told to keep my remarks rather
brief we have an action-packed hour for
everyone first thank you very much for
getting up before 8 a.m. and arriving
we're trying something new at
commencement this year which I'll
explain in a moment but first I promise
just a couple remarks on the first day
went both our undergraduates and
graduate students arrived I tell
everyone that there is nothing that the
faculty and staff at Cornell want one
more than for all of you to succeed and
so this is a culmination of that success
so thank you for succeeding thank you
parents and friends for helping your
students to succeed and thank you to the
faculty for all the work you put in to
get to where we are with these folks
today I've had the pleasure of getting
to know many of you and it's remarkable
to me how much each of you has taken
control of either your schoolwork or
your research project and really found
your own voice and I think that's so
important as students as you move
forward to remember that voice and to
continue to use that voice and one of
the things that many of you know I'm
very passionate about is using your
voice to connect to the public and the
communities that you move to so I
sincerely hope that each of you will use
your voice to speak to those with whom
you agree and to speak with those with
whom you might not agree but to use your
voice to bring people together and to
bridge the gap that sometimes
between the public and our academic
institutions so with that we're going to
start our festivities we are today
honoring undergraduate majors in the
plant sciences and Agricultural Sciences
along with our graduate students in the
fields of horticulture plant biology
plant breeding plant pathology and
plants my group on biology soil and crop
sciences and what we're going to do
today for the first time so be a bit
patient with us if you would as we are
actually going to have the director of
undergraduate studies the section chair
for each of our graduate fields along
with the major advisor for each student
the major advisor will in fact put the
hood on to each candidate I did some
research into the history of the hooding
ceremony and it actually comes from
ancient while older times in in Europe
and specifically in England and and it
was a sign of the difference that there
was between those who were in academia
and those were who were not and the the
term it's not that the term town and
gown actually originated during those
times and and I think that these days we
hope to bring town and gown together and
through the ceremony well we are being
hooded we'll also remember that we are
the town so without further ado we are
going to start with the field of
horticulture the certificate will be
presented to each graduate by dr. Steve
riders share of the horticulture section
and each graduate will be announced by
dr. William Miller who is our director
of Graduate Studies Thank You Preston
good morning everyone where we have four
candidates who have earned advanced
degrees in this academic year and we
would like to start with
in fact my student Isabelle bass drum
and so Isabel Michael I believe the idea
is that you come up and it Isabel worked
with me on a master's degree and she
worked on post-harvest physiology of
tulips
[Applause]
is Yoshi Harada here we think yoshi has
not been here yoshi has heard his PhD in
horticulture with with professor nina
Masek and Tom Whitlow and he worked on
biogeochemistry of the Brooklyn range
and urban rooftop farm so if we don't
have Yoshi let's give
our next candidate is is Al Pacheco
Kowalewski PhD in horticulture working
with Bruce rice and Jason Londo based in
the Geneva Experiment Station which is
about an hour north of here and I'll
work on aspects of cold hardiness and
dormancy in grapevines oh now I see
[Applause]
and our final candidate in horticulture
is grant Thompson
PhD and grant earned his PhD with Jenny
Cal Kniffin and the topic of his
dissertation was implications of land
use legacy on soil micro biomes of urban
grasslands
[Applause]
[Music]
thank you very much
[Music]
okay moving on to the Graduate field of
plant biology dr. Mike Scanlon will be
announcing our graduates dr. Klaus Van
Wyck section chair will be handing out
for certificates thank you Chris I'm
proud to announce a three PhDs today in
plant biology
the first one is Daniela Lovato she got
a PhD for her work on evolution of
biochemical diversity in pilo carcass is
a combined fellow genetic and
environmental analysis should be hooded
by her advisor dr. Kevin Nixon
[Applause]
[Music]
electric shipment is Camilla Martinez
Akiyama and she did her work on two Sena
so Sena sword Flores from South America
Padova climactic and petty ultima tree
emphasis professor was dr. will bill
prepare shall be hooded by dr. Lujan de
Gandolfo Nixon
a next data Robinson to secure PhD for
our work on ploidy and size in the
rabbit at Sasebo our advisor is dr.
Adrian motor
[Applause]
[Music]
congratulations
[Applause]
[Music]
next we have the field of plant breeding
let's see the section Chair of the field
of plant breeding Jeff Doyle will be
handing out certificates and I will be
announcing for the field the first
candidate is Augustine Valverde who
received an MS in plant breeding his
advisor dr. Margaret Smith and Larry
smart will be hooding Houston today his
thesis was dial analysis of corn hybrids
at different level of disease resistance
and development of a selection index
method based on production outcomes and
responses to interact nose stop
our next candidate is Craig Carlson his
major advisor dr. Larry smart he's
giving a PhD his dissertation topic the
genomic basis of heterosis in
high-yielding triploid willow Salix
species bioenergy crops
[Applause]
our next candidate will go to cool
Nathaniel Ikki Agora's on your Canon
dissertation topic high-throughput
phenotyping and genomics assisted
reading for quality traits Posada
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
well my next candidate Roberto
Lozano PhD of my breeding dissertation
advisor dr. Jean Luc's adding
dissertation topic functional genomics
to a genomic prediction models in
cassava
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our next candidate Alfred Sumati
PhD in plant breeding advisor dr. Salvin
genic the Janik lab has been very busy
this year
mr. tasted topic genome-wide critics
genome-wide predictions for resistance
to cassava Brown Street disease and
yield trends
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
our next candidate is Nicholas sent
Antonio PhD of my reading
advisor dr. Marc Sorrells dissertation
topic homie Elega SEPA stasis in week
the search for an immortal hybrid
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
our next candidate having trouble
reading this morning parents Christine
deeper bra sorry PhD in plant breeding
her advisor is dr. dr. Michael Gore
dissertation topic genetics of Pro
vitamin A and vitamin e levels in Mays
grand
[Applause]
[Music]
that's okay for those of you who
couldn't hear that Mike just told in the
world as yours
our next candidate Kitty [ __ ] Samson boo
PhD in plant green advisor dr. Dunn vias
dissertation topic breeding switchgrass
for resistance to by Polaris diseases
[Applause]
we'll now move on to the field of plant
pathology and plant microbiology section
chair Gary Bergstrom will be handing out
certificates and I will be announcing
its may or may not be a good thing our
first candidate is me man
Megan Diego Daniel's PhD in Plant
Pathology and plant microbiology advisor
ducks dr. Kathy Hodge Megan's
dissertation title rustic food spoilage
cell fungi and a new Apple disease
a second candidate for Plant Pathology
and plant microbiology is not here today
Mickey dra is also receiving a PhD and
his advisor is dr. Michael Milgram so
congratulations
the final field that we'll be
recognizing this morning
is the field of soil and crop science
the director of graduate studies for the
field or Lena
Molina that ammonia will be announcing
and section chair Tim Center will be
handing out certificates
this is my great pleasure at the to
recognize students in crop sciences we
have two great days this year and the
first students is Lila convey a logical
and thermochemical conversion of human
soul and waste to fertilizers and soil
conditioners
the second student is Michael Schmidt
advisor and Martinez the dissertation
pieces Arastoo angstroms
studies of organic matter Manoa
interaction across scales
and now it's my great pleasure to
introduce Don Wiles professor in one
breeding in genetics also associate dean
and director of academic program School
announced bring the morale of the wards
okay remainin I have the privilege of
presenting the Charles a ring Memorial
Award to two of our graduating seniors
in the plant sciences major and this
award is given on the basis of their
scholastic achievement so I'm going to
announce their names right now so you
can make your way up while I say a few
things about the award itself so the two
students serves our end then and Matthew
seaman so if you could please come
[Music]
for each of these two students will
receive two things one is a certificate
that's signed by the plant sciences
curriculum committee and also the Dean
of the college and they will also
receive a three hundred seventy five
dollar check for each one of them now
the money for the check actually came
from the payout of an endowment that was
left by Charles a ring really over 100
years ago was 1913 when this endowment
was given the Cornell and it was given
for the advancement of plant sciences
but but it was also given because and
I'm reading a quote here that comes out
of the archives that says because my
father dr. William rank was a personal
friend of the founder of this University
also an acknowledgement of the great
assistance the university has been to me
on my farm so I'd like to congratulate
both of these students on behalf of the
faculty and staff in a play of Sciences
major and again on behalf of College
Dean says there in congratulating
like to invite Tony de Tomaso to come to
the podium for the next part of our
program tony is a professor and
sectioning of soil and crop sciences
he's also the director of undergraduate
studies in the agricultural sciences
major Tony alright we're now getting to
the really exciting part which is
honoring our undergraduates in the
agricultural science of Plant Sciences
majors just one of us on that
regretfully professional Margaret Fritz
who's the director of undergraduate
studies for the plain science major and
his son Kevin is graduating this morning
in the Department of Entomology so he
couldn't be here so hence why I'll be
covering the dual purposes of announcing
our undergraduates for you fair
appearance friends just want to tell you
this is an amazing group of students I
mean you look at what they've achieved
in the four years they've been the
Grinnell Lurie in some cases even less
than that it's truly amazing and I'm
expecting some great things from all of
them so with that just I'd like to know
how this is going to work I'm going to
be announcing the names of the students
in both majors in alphabetical order so
it'll be a mix of act science and plant
science I will mention also what the
green are getting in many cases there
we've got double majors here I II D
students are definitely high achievers
and also letting you know if they have
any Latin honors and distinction in
research so with that I will begin with
Tyrell Archer
[Applause]
[Music]
I'm so glad or enough to hood 35
students 1770 our next student is Dennis
attea
and I'll just mention as Dennis walks
appeared that for Kyra Archer because I
was giving the handing it at handing out
the diploma sorry I didn't mention touch
she's a double major in nutritional
science and plant sciences and also has
graduated with distinction in research
so Carol congratulate mr. zalto a double
major in agricultural science and animal
science and graduates [ __ ] laude
Chris Christopher me come on up
I think placeless grown like six inches
since you started at Cornell first is a
Bachelors of Science in Agricultural
Sciences graduation
[Music]
creditors we call them blue believin
thong in ABS 200 cultural sciences
[Music]
punk boys
[Music]
pop is receiving a Bachelor of Science
in agricultural scientists and graduate
school melodic Nexus nana region
not as receiving a double major in
agricultural sciences and plant science
she's our anything eat breakfast heavier
Patricia Jen come on up many having
graduates with a bachelor's in plant
science and also a [ __ ] laude honors
one of the best botanists I've ever met
- Carlson - graduates with a bachelor's
in plant science in Magnum [ __ ] laude
very impressive
William nah
William graduates with a Bachelors of
Science in the plant sciences
shall we
Kelly graduates with a Bachelors of
Science in the plant sciences
[Music]
Elsa the better
[Music]
elsa graduates with a Bachelors of
Science in plant science and kumoi de
honors
Megan Dodd
Megan is a double major in animal
sciences and plants I'm she's covering
it off this is ready
next is Felix Fernandez penny
makes completes a Bachelors of Science
in plant science and graduates Magnum to
love it
he was in my class so he should be
shaking my grades are still coming just
kidding
hi Cassidy Fletcher come on up Cassidy
Cassidy's graduating the Agricultural
Sciences with a [ __ ] laude honors
Nellie we're up Kelly
Nellie completed a Bachelor of Science
in agricultural scientists Pangburn
Harris come on up Haley
they don't believe in Bachelors of
Science in the agricultural sciences
Sarah Hetrick tomorrow
so sarah has double majors agricultural
sciences plant scientist homebody and
distinction in research
Bayley Hopkins Hensley come on up Bailey
baby penguins for the bachelors in the
plant sciences
in Nicholas terrible Mia's
linguist graduates with a bachelor's in
agricultural sciences in math magna [ __ ]
laude
Zeron Lynn come on
so zero at complete has completed a
bachelor's in the black Sciences
graduate summa [ __ ] laude and with
distinction in research congratulate
Kelsey Mackenzie doubles be the
Minnesota contingent here
[Applause]
Kelsea graduates with a bachelor's in
agricultural sciences and honors [ __ ]
laude
clearly major come on up Katie any
graduates with a Bachelors of Science in
the plant sciences
[Applause]
grace Montgomery bring square 20 with a
bachelors in the agricultural sciences
and magna [ __ ] laude
Carrie Mullins
very graduates with a Bachelors of
Science in agricultural sciences in
magna [ __ ] laude
Allyson Barrett
Alex and also graduates with a
bachelor's in Ag Sciences and is also a
magna [ __ ] laude
Natalie gross
not only graduates with a Bachelors of
Science in the plant sciences we got one
year done but the rains passed by our
grading routers come on a rainy
[Music]
Britany graduates with a Bachelors of
Science in the Indiana cultural sciences
Samantha Schultz Samantha graduates with
a Bachelors of Science in the plant
sciences
Silvia yes
Sigyn just left her graduate work to
come here from Texas so this is
impressive in the middle of her research
[Applause]
double majoring in agricultural sciences
and plant sciences
[Applause]
mantium graduates with a bachelor's in
planck science and summa [ __ ] laude
in the polls Miranda with over to
receiving the Bachelors of Science in
Agricultural Sciences and honors [ __ ]
laude
Madeline start formatting sorry husband
are
and he graduates with a Bachelor of
Science in the agricultural sciences
Benjamin swore
then she graduates with a Bachelor of
Science in plant sciences in magna [ __ ]
laude
mr. Eric Martinez is he here yes
Aaron graduates with a Bachelors of
Science in the plant sciences
[Applause]
take these graduates for the Bachelors
of Science in in Plant Sciences and
distinction in research
don't face you
take back wings with a bachelors in
plant science and magna [ __ ] laude
certainly last but not least is windage
Oh
[Applause]
graduates The Bachelor of Science in
agricultural scientists and a boom body
[Music]
oh okay I will now see some words of
wisdom so just like couple of things for
our PhD masters graduate students and
our undergraduates and family and all of
your friends and parents as a faculty
member I can say and speech for our
other faculty members here and those
that are not here but it's been a
pleasure it's been a pleasure we've had
the highs and lows but it's been a
pleasure to have been a part of your
hopefully in some cases your kids in
sons and daughters they're kind of
progressing through Cornell and what
they've learned a lot but we've learned
a lot as faculty and it's probably one
of the things that I personally but I
know a lot of my fellow faculty members
enjoy is to be part of something that's
greater than us and I always tell these
students if I could get to Cornell I
could be a faculty member here you guys
couldn't do it and so I just want to
really thank all of you certainly thank
the graduates but thank the parents
family friends for supporting our
students in the plant sciences and in
the agricultural science and certainly
our graduate programs and I know I speak
for all of us to thank you and we really
wish the best for these young folks I
know they're going to do some great
things and I want to hear from all of
you we want to hear from you as to where
some of the next career path is and oh
the most important part this is just an
actual food is important right after the
graduation ceremony is sold off we will
be meeting in trinium which is the
urgent kennedy hall that's that'll be
about 1215 or so right right after the
ceremony and Irby lunch will be served
so please come back and this is a great
chance for all of us faculty and others
to interact with you family members
graduate so please don't forget that
right after just sort of when he's done
over a Chilean if you're not sure where
that is just ask anybody I'm sure
they'll be they'll be happy to tell you
oh I cannot forget to thank the two
folks that have organized this you can
see a deep red for léa léa fermion
Carrie Richards we really have to thank
[Music]
you know how they say there's always
somebody the ideas somebody else's
facade these are the folks that have
really been in the trenches for us and
the students know them all of our
graduates and undergraduates and faculty
we really appreciate their would help
their help the little details are most
as faculty don't kind of think about
they're there to do it so thank you guys
again congratulations and we'll see you
hopefully a trillium after the ceremony
risotto field thank you everyone
[Music]
I was just wondering Carrie or Leah was
this supposed to be a good picture of
the graduates on stage plant science
majors on stage and we'll see if the
excellent students do have to take a
picture
you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at Cornell edu